Demain, 16h, place de la République à Paris,
y a 1 nouvelle manifestation contre la loi
d'armanin Le Pen
qui va avoir lieu, hein,
cette fameuse coalition d'extrême droite,
ou le gouvernement qui prétendait faire barrage,
qui prétendait que l'extrême droite sera pas pour
avec lui, bah il applique son programme.
Marine Le Pen, elle salue 1 victoire idéologique.
Il faut qu'on se batte contre cette loi, parce que,
en attaquant tous les étrangers,
en fait, ils visent à précariser
l'entièreté des conditions de travail
de tous les ouvriers,
de tous les pauvres en France,
sans le voir avec les étudiants, hein,
ils attaquent,
ils augmentent, euh,
les frais d'inscription pour les
étudiants à l'étranger,
et ensuite ils vont faire quoi ?
Bah ils vont les augmenter pour tout le monde,
et ça, si on le comprend pas,
on va pas y arriver,
on comprend rien. Donc
il faut qu'on se batte contre cette loi.
Aujourd'hui, dans la société française,
y a rien qui tourne sans les immigrés,
sans les travailleurs étrangers,
sans les travailleurs sans-papiers,
on le voit avec les JO, hein,
quand les sans-papiers,
ils décident
de se mettre en grève pour obtenir la régularisation,
bah y a plus de chantier.
Et c'est peut-être vers ça en fait,
qu'il faut qu'on aille
toutes et tous vers 1 mouvement de grave,
extrêmement large,
qui fasse l'alliance
entre les Français qui ont des papiers,
ceux qui n'en ont pas,
parce que sinon on va perdre.
Donc rendez-vous 16h place de la République,
euh. Demain à Paris,
il faut qu'on soit nombreux et
nombreuses pour mettre fin à
assez loin raciste.
Y a déjà eu des blocages,
y a déjà eu des manifestations dans
énormément de villes de France hier et aujourd'hui.
Il faut que le mouvement, il s'amplifie
parce qu'en réalité, avec eux, y a pas de trêve de Noël,
c'est toujours l'exploitation,
c'est toujours le harcèlement policier.